-Salut je suis toujours au parc de Belleville
Et je suis avec Tiffany et Geoffrey. On va essayer de voir ce qu'il se passe
dans la tête de Tiffany, qu'est ce qu'il se passe dans la tête d'une fille en fait !
-Hm, ok ! J'sais pas
-Bah oui, c'est ce qu'on a vu, on a vu un vrai doute dans ton regard !
-Nous on va essayer de trouver à quelle carte elle pense.
C'est pas si évidemment que ça.
Notre but, à Geoffrey et à moi, c'est de retrouver quelle carte tu as en tête maintenant, ok ?
T'as qu'une carte et une seule carte en tête ? T'en as une belle image mentale ?
-Oui, ça y est.
-Oui, super ! Vous pouvez essayer de le faire en même temps que nous.
La 1ere étape ça va être de jouer sur les choses qui sont binaires
donc là rouge ou noir, on va chercher si sa carte est rouge ou noire.
Tu vas regarder Tiffany, Tiffany tu penses à ta carte
Et j'vais dire "rouge noir rouge noir etc" en alternant.
A chaque fois que je dis ta couleur, si c'est rouge ou si c'est noir, tu penses "stop" dans ta tête
-Ah d'accord, j'dis rien !
-Tu l'dis pas, ok ?
-Donc ta carte...
-Va pas trop vite !
-.. ta carte peut être rouge, noire, rouge, noire, rouge, noire...
Il se passe des choses entre vous c'est dingue ! *rires*
Alors est-ce que t'as perçu une différence ou pas déjà, de base ? Oui, non ?
-Un p'tit peu mais je suis pas sûr de moi.
-Tu dirais que c'est quoi ?
-Je dirais noir mais...
-Moi je dirais que c'est noir aussi. Et c'est ?
-C'est noir !
-Et c'est noir ! On a bon ! Don du coup comme on sait que c'est noir on va chercher
entre trèfle et pique. On garde la même méthode ?
-Ok, on garde la même méthode.
-Est-ce que tu peux regarder vers là maintenant ? Comme eux ils peuvent le faire sur toi
et toi t'essayes de l'faire en même temps que moi.
*gens qui chantent* C'est les chants corses ! *rires*
Ils parlent de Belleville ! *rires*
Tu penses à ta carte ça peut être trèfle, pique, trèfle, pique, trèfle, pique, allez j'arrête là.
Est-ce que tu as une idée ?
-Trèfle.
-Alors moi j'dirais que c'est pique en l'occurence, alors j'vais te dire pourquoi je pense que c'est pique
peut-être je me trompe mais en fait, au delà des expressions, j'sais pas si vous,  vous avez vu,
t'avais comme un hochement de tête, c'est très léger hein, c'est une micro expression mais elle acquiesçait
quelque chose, comme si elle validait inconsciemment donc je dirais que c'est pique..
-C'est pique !
-Oui, c'est lui qu'a répondu hein ! *rires* Ok c'est pique !
Je sais pas si vous entendez mais y a quelqu'un qui chante la Marseillaise en écho derrière. Vous avez pas entendu ?
-Non !
-Y a des battles de chanteurs, c'est pas The Voice mais on s'est retourné quand même !
Maintenant tu vas dire, toi même toutes les cartes de l'as au roi en allant le plus vite possible.
Tu fais " 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8 etc", c'est parti, on t'écoute, ils t'écoutent !
-Ok, attends parce qu'il faut que j'me souvienne de toutes les cartes ! *rires*
Euh, 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10, valets ?
-C'est parfait, tu peux t'arrêter là. J'vous explique ce qu'il s'est passé...
-T'as déjà une idée des cartes alors ?
-Mais bien sûr ! Déjà j'ai éliminer l'as parce que je t'ai tendu un piège grossier, j't'ai dis :"tu dis 1,2,3,4,5,6 et tu répète comme moi"
t'as redis :"1,2,3", si tu avais pris l'as, tu aurais pas dis "1", tu aurais corriger avec l'as et ça tu l'as pas fait.
T'as clairement ralenti au niveau du 10 car comme je me mets un peu la pression t'as envie de partir sur 11,12,13
Et comme c'est filmé, t'as pas envie de faire ça.
-Mais non, j'ai pas envie de faire de bêtise !
-Du coup t'as ralenti et après t'as commencé à placer les autres cartes. T'aurais jamais ralenti
si t'avais anticipé les autres cartes et les aurais anticipé si c'était ta carte qu'était la dame, le valet, le roi ou voire même le 10
Donc ta carte elle est située entre le 2 et le 9. Déjà, je t'ai un peu mâché le travail.
-A toi de faire le reste !
-J'dirais même avant 7, avant 6 !
-Ouais, moi j'dis ça aussi, je pense savoir la carte précisément en tête..Est-ce qu'on a raison pour le moment ?
-Oui !
-Oui, est ce que tu veux faire un essai ? Tu lui donnes pas, tu lui confirmes pas hein
-Moi j'aurais dis 4... 4 ou 5 un truc comme ça
-Pas mal, moi j'suis plus faible j'aurais dis 2 mais peut-être j'suis pas bon
Moi j'dirais que c'est le 2 de pique, toi le 4 de pique, c'est quoi la carte que t'as en tête ?
-C'est le 2 de pique.
-Le 2 de pique ! Yeaaaah !
Merci Joeffrey, Zebulon qui arrive, ça va ça t'as plu ?
-Très bien !
-T'as pas tout trouvé... Mais presque !
-Non mais bon, je suis pas encore mentaliste ! *rires*
-Nooon mais t'as raison en fait. Le vrai pouvoir, c'est de faire croire qu'on en as pas ! Donc tu vois, en faisant ça,
elle va pas se méfier de toi, et là tu vas pouvoir obtenir tout ce que tu veux... *rires*
Et toi ça t'as plu Tiffany ?
-Ouais ça va, ça va tout va bien !
-"Ouais ça vaaa" *rires*
Si la prestation de Joeffrey, de Tiffany et de moi-même vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir
grâce à un "Pouce en l'air" ! Vous pouvez commenter parce que je suis persuadé qu'ils vont lire les commentaires en fait
parce qu'ils vont stresser, ils vont lire tous les commentaires ! Vous pouvez aussi vous abonner en cliquant ici,
dans le petit coin supérieur gauche de votre écran, mais alors si je recarde on est foutus après hein ! *rires* C'est ça le truc !
Merci beaucoup et rendez-vous demain pour le prochain mental vlog, il sera à 17h, tchao !
-Tcha-Tchao !
*générique de fin*